vous aviez vu cette affiche ou pas cette
affiche-moi je l'ai pas vu
merci cacahuète
moi je vais commencer je vais me
présenter un artiste du quartier
d'accord appelle cacahuète d'accord et
je viens du quartier Pablo Picasso pas
de la Tour exactement comme j'ai pu
l'entendre tout à l'heure c'est ça je
suis dans le quartier
moi vraiment si je suis venu ce soir
c'est ça me fait vraiment pas ça me fait
même pas plaisir de venir pour de vrai
c'est juste que je vois comment mon
quartier en gros il est affiché partout
ça fait pas plaisir c'est ça des gens
sur leur adresse ils ont pas de
l'opiasso avenue Pablo Picasso ils vont
aller chercher du travail tout ça des
gens de mon âge des jeunes tout ça
finalement ils peuvent se faire refouler
pour ça c'est
quand il y a des gens qui viennent de
ton quartier parfois il y a une
discrimination lui prend même pas pour
travailler tout ça moi j'ai pas dit ça
mais ça peut arriver là j'étais sur BFM
je me suis réveillé un matin j'étais sur
BFM j'ai vu les dealers du quartier
Pablo Picasso ça c'est pas un truc aussi
ils font ils font des journées
c'est nos amis quand ils veulent BFM
non non mais je te le dis BFM ils ont
quand même ils pensent d'abord à
valaudience
il y a plein d'artistes il y a des
mannequins il y a plein de trucs il y a
des concerts qui et on a retenu que ça
en fait et on retient que ça touche pas
il y a aussi ça mais ça est-ce que c'est
une Nanterre ou c'est partout en fait en
fait cacahuète ce qu'il est en train de
dire c'est cuit c'est un artiste il
aurait aimé qu'on l'a invite en tant
qu'artiste et qu'on parle
plutôt que de parler de ça c'est ça et
comme vous avez dit comme je vous ai dit
c'est pas Nanterre le problème ça c'est
un problème qui a dans c'est en France
en France aux États-Unis la drogue des
trucs comme ça c'est partout ouais c'est
ça mais c'est pas un enterre le problème
c'est que c'est une mentir en gros
pardon en gros on se fait afficher comme
si en gros à Nanterre en gros c'était
dentaire que ça se passait ils écrivent
Pablo Picasso en gros tout le quartier
il y a des gens ils ont rien à voir là
il y a depuis là il y a des renforcement
policiers des choses comme ça
il y a des trucs qui sont pas
nécessaires en fait ça il y a des trucs
je sais pas comment dire
tu veux que je te dise moi je suis un
peu d'accord avec cacahuète moi si si
facile parce que ici des habitants
justement
et quand la police ils viennent je suis
pas tout le temps tranquille
pourtant mais cacahuète au-delà de ça ce
que tu dis quand tu dis on parle juste
de votre quartier pour montrer voilà que
voilà dans la tête des gens c'est voilà
le quartier Pablo Picasso maintenant
c'est juste un quartier de dealer ce que
lente est-ce que tu es en train de dire
cacahuète c'est qu'il y a pas que ça il
y a plein de gens qui qui travaillent
majorités exactement voilà la majorité
c'est pas ça non mais c'est ça oui mais
au-delà de de ce point-là ce qui est
choquant c'est le ton du règlement qui
circule et en fait on a l'impression que
c'est tellement démocratisé qu'on a
l'impression que c'est devenu un
commerce comme un autre ça parle
d'employé ça parle d'horaire on a
l'impression qu'il parle du travail et
c'est eux qui dictent la loi c'est
complètement hallucinant là où la police
a du mal à malheureusement à se faire
respecter donc c'est vrai que ces
affiches elles sont choquantes voilà
merci de respecter notre quotidien les
horaires des employés etc on a
l'impression qu'on parle d'un Comex ma
commerce lambda ici
moi j'ai une question
ensuite là là tout de suite vous me
dites vous avez l'impression qu'en gros
c'est choquant vous voulez que je fasse
quoi ah mais rien moi je suis juste venu
vous dire
non mais justement pour votre sécurité
enfin pour votre tranquillité quand
qu'on s'inquiète votre votre façon en
gros c'est pour ne tranquillité qu'on
s'inquiète vous dites c'est pour notre
tranquillité là que je suis là mais au
final je suis pas tranquille là je vais
repartir là ça se trouve là je vais me
faire arrêter par la peau parce que là
je vous explique je dis pas que c'est
tous les policiers mais dans ce problème
dans ce pays on sait qu'il y a des
problèmes entre la police et les jeunes
donc vous risquez plus de la police que
des dealers c'est ce que vous êtes en
moi je vous ai même pas parler des
dealers je ne sais pas alors de quoi il
y en a ou pas des dealers est-ce que ça
vous dérange c'est comme je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est un problème qui a
aux États-Unis qui a partout dans toutes
dans tous les pays
cacahuète on vient simplement tu es
invité parce que il y a des dealers qui
font la loi ils disent aux autres si
vous voulez pas être emmerdé faut nous
laisser faire notre trafic est-ce que
toi exactement moi regardez-moi moi je
suis venu et je vous ai dit moi la
lettre je vous ai dit je l'ai pas vu de
mes yeux moi j'ai été sur BFM un jour
j'ai vu le quartier Pablo Picasso tout
ça je suis sorti c'était plus pareil
alors que j'avais rien remarqué de
dehors comme ça permet de Deal dans
votre quartier ça n'existe pas
la question mais moi je vous ai pas dit
qu'il y avait pas remarqué la vérité
moi ce sujet moi en fait il me saoule
non non
je comprends cacahuète moi-même ce sujet
il me saoule en fait moi je vous dis
arrêter je suis une m'intéresse pas
voilà je vous dis la vérité j'ai décidé
de m'intéresse pas je pense que c'est
voilà c'est pourtant c'est revenir sur
les poils non non mais non non oui oui
bien sûr Claudine fédéral bien sûr la
consommation
le problème de cacahuète qui va rien
changer pour rien voilà c'est pour ça
non mais en fait cacahuète le pauvre
Vivien là et on on a l'impression qu'il
il est responsable lui il est pas resté
mais non justement
sur une une banlieue trap ou je sais
plus quoi on est bien montre que des
trucs dégueulasse trap c'est pas ça si
j'écoutais Nora trap c'était
Saint-Germain boulevard Saint-Germain
elle va défendre la vérité si trappes
c'est ça il y en a qui s'en sortent un
Elka et tout ça qui font mais
la violence évidemment comme partout il
y a un appartement
mais pas partout c'est pas pareil
débuter Argenteuil ou débiter boulevard
Saint-Germain je te promets ça c'est un
truc justement
ils peuvent s'énerver mais il faut dire
il faut un buteur il faut non ce que je
regarde par là c'est arrêter de dire
là-bas c'est très bien il y a des gens
très bien oui mais la majorité du temps
la base qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que
c'est accidentogène c'est que c'est
dangereux d'y être que vous dites parce
que vous y êtes pas
un truc moi on fait des barbecues on
fait plein de choses
Mathieu Mathieu se régalé Mathieu tu tu
débarques d'où Matthieu tu crois
vraiment que les journalistes ils vont y
aller ils vont dire tiens on va les
filmer un un truc un centre un centre où
il y a des gens qui font des des des des
dollars de l'art plastique on va dire on
va on va il filme le sensationnel arrête
de dire des bêtises maintenant il dit
que les chiffres explosent alors de 10
de trafic de règlement et pourquoi la
police ne peut pas rentrer à 93
est-ce que tu es en train de dire quand
tu dis des journalistes pourquoi il fume
ça les journalistes ils filment ce qui
est sensationniste bah bien sûr ils vont
pas les filmer cacahuètes qui fait des
toiles et qui dit voilà c'est un artiste
ou qui chante ou qui non ils vont pas
ils vont pas les filmer ça je suis
désolé
comme tout le monde il cherche
l'audience crois-moi et tu le sais bien
prononcer puisque tu es très ami avec
des gens de BFM merci
à ce sujet les autres parce que c'est
pas bien sûr france télé ils cherchent
l'audience toi par contre tu cherches à
te faire virer merci Beney non mais pour
revenir à ce sujet pourquoi on on montre
cette affiche parce que cette affiche
pardonnez-moi mais elle elle pose
problème pour les gens qui habitent
c'est pas là nous on s'est passé pas les
gens qui habitent qu'on pointe du doigt
c'est les dealers qui emmerdent les gens
qui habitent donc voilà c'est pour ça là
on va aller dans une dans une autre
ville il y aura juste pas cette affiche
par exemple ça va être la même chose
mais il y aura pas forcément
il faut il faut qu'on dénonce tous les
endroits dis-leur en merde les gens qui
habitent moi je vois ça
les habitants etc voilà mais évidemment
je préférais qu'on les vire de qu'on les
vire là on a qu'à mettre des caméras
fragile si on mettait les caméras les
dealers
non mais les dealers ils sont là de
toute façon qui est affiche ou pas
fiches ils sont là bah je préfère qu'ils
mettent une lettre oui c'est bourré de
fautes et cetera mais ils disent qu'ils
vont essayer de déditer des règles de
voilà plutôt qui menacent les gens qui
rentrent dans les immeubles qui le les
tabassent et cetera voilà après c'est
plutôt la police faire son travail qu'on
mette des caméras qu'on contrôle les
gens
cacahuète moi j'ai une question
personne pourquoi
on dirait que vous savez et ben moi j'ai
une autre question pourquoi la police
peut pas rentrer dans la plupart des
cités mais vous êtes jamais venu vous
dites tu veux faire rentrer depuis tout
à l'heure moi j'habite depuis tout à
l'heure parce que je vous ai demandé
tout de suite vous êtes déjà venu à 9h
mais tout de suite vous m'avez pas
répondu non non il est passé
en tout cas vous voulez pas répondre ça
c'est vous mais en tout cas moi ce que
je vous dis c'est que maintenant la
police là ils sont tout le temps à
Nanterre ils sont pas 4 ils sont dans
plein de quartier et bakarcher l'autre
ça peut différer c'est la super sécurité
ça va être super sécurisant attends
attends j'ai la réponse de Nora qui nous
regarde alors
ido elle m'a dit tu peux dire à
Delormeau de sortir son cul de sa Tour
d'Argent et de ne pas déformer mes
propos et surtout qu'il parle de télé ou
de blouson en jean mais pour le reste
qu'il reste à sa place il connaît rien
enfin
ça c'est énorme oui c'est pas moi ah
ouais
voilà
sans transition sans transition Delphine
non mais t'inquiète
sur des zones quand les gens sont
tellement habitués à ce qu'il y a du
trafic de drogue et que ça se passe mal
et qui se sentent plus chez eux et qui
se sentent pas en sécurité du coup on en
vient à penser qu'un petit mot comme ça
ça devient charmant et sympathique et
encore une fois on marche sur la tête ça
c'est la France d'un Gilles et en France
des petits mots parce qu'en fait c'est
pas on veut pas les petits mots des
dealers on veut juste pas les dealers
tout court donc voilà
le seul truc que j'ai à dire c'est moi
je défends personne je suis pas du du
moi les voisins je suis franchement je
suis désolé pour eux ça les dérange et
moi je suis pour rien moi je connais pas
les personnes qu'on fait ça moi ce que
je vous dis juste c'est dans chaque tous
les tous les dealers là par exemple moi
je dis je sais pas mais moi je vous dis
qu'en gros les dealers ils ont une mère
la mère se trouve elle a des amis dans
le quartier c'est elle aussi elle a des
amis d'autres mamans des trucs ça veut
dire qu'au final qui vous dites qui
terrorisent les gens je sais pas moi
mais moi en gros moi je peux pas vous
mentir
j'ai pas d'avis sur ça c'est dommage moi
j'ai vraiment pas d'investissement on va
voir ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs
tiens à mon avis ascenseur oui à 85 %
là ce que tu viens de dire tu as dit si
ils ont une mère ils vont pas ils vont
pas traumatiser les gens mais si non
c'est quoi ce que tu as dit que si il y
a les dealers par exemple ils ont une
merde donc qui vous dit que forcément il
terrorise les gens ça se trouve que la
mer aussi parce que moi moi je connais
des moments qui essaient de raisonner
leur fils qui les écoutent pas tout ça
et ça veut pas dire qu'en gros il était
terroristes ça se trouve que les mamans
elles sont même elles sont plus à parler
aux dealer que vous le pensez à toutes
les problèmes les voisins mais les les
dans la tour par exemple ça se trouve
qu'il peut avoir une maman qui essaie de
les raisonner qu'ils ont peur merci
merci cacahuète